bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour ensemble de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec à mes côtés
michael à metz beaux joyaux bonjour dans
les titres cette semaine l'ump choisi
son nouveau président c'est la fin ce
week end une longue campagne interne
entre nicolas sarkozy bruno le maire et
hervé mariton dernière ligne droite
c'est le rendez vous incontournable des
mères la mère tenait son congrès annuel
cette semaine porte de versailles autre
réforme des rythmes scolaires la belle
dotation et les nouvelles cartes de
france d'homère ont le blues et l'ont
fait savoir
il y à 40 ans débutait les débats sur la
loi veil à cette occasion un téléfilm
revient sur le combat de simone veil
s'est le plus de l'hebdo et à
l'assemblée les députés ont voté une
proposition de résolution pour
réaffirmer le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
notre invité cette semaine pour
commenter toute cette actualité
christian jacob bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député ump de l'oise le président
au dessus des normes de cdm de députés a
évidemment de cdma le président du
groupe ump à l'assemblée nationale
vous connaissez le principe de cette
émission il ya un portrait qui a réalisé
ce portrait réalisé et bien par les
parlementaires eux mêmes qui vont parler
de vous propose de les écouter et on
revient juste après pour rediscuter le
calme des vieilles troupes ancrée dans
le terroir ça c'est christian jacob qui
a énormément de qualités et qui
véritablement est souvent méconnue mais
il est clair que c'est un excellent
président groupe
je dirais pas qu'il est sectaire parce
que je crois pas que l'on puisse dire
quand ces prises de position se soient
animés par le sectarisme mais en
revanche que défense un peu 1,13 et
intransigeante des membres de son groupe
et puis c'est pas facile tous les jours
d'être président du groupe ump quand on
sait toutes les divisions qu'il y avait
au sein du groupe ump christian jacob
pour moi c'est la fidélité en politique
ne partageons pas les mêmes convictions
mais c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
parce que il est fidèle à jacques chirac
à qui il doit je crois une grande partie
de sa carrière
humainement j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour lui pour cette raison je voudrais
revenir sur cette question de fidélité
vous avez été fidèle à jacques chirac
vous êtes un fidèle également à jean
françois copé pour rester toujours
fidèle jean françois copé oui bien sûr
il ya d'amitié alors les relations
amicales entre jacques chirac et jean
françois copé revient sur les rentes et
pour jacques chirac à la fois une
admiration énorme très grand respect et
puis effectivement beaucoup d'amitié
jean-françois s'éteint c'est un ami de
de combat politique on a une relation
qui équipent différentes mais qui est
aussi très amicale et qui leur est bien
évidemment sa fidélité sa paye aux
politiques aussi oui on le sujet voilà
on l'est on l'est pas fidèle bon voilà
on n'oublie pas assez ses amis on passe
c'est la vie politique est difficile
elle est dure
on donne des coups pendant qu'elle a
beaucoup entendu cette phrase oui je
suis pas convaincu de sa part convaincu
de cela en revanche il faut se tenir sur
quelques quelques lignes et les liens
d'amitié moi je savais j'ai conservé les
amis de syndicalisme il ya 25 ans j'ai
quitté le syndicalisme conservait
d'autres sur les sur les bancs d'école
je crois cette valeur de l'amitié
alors évidemment des semaines commence
par lundi et le lundi le président de la
république tient ses promesses
françois hollande avait promis de
revenir chaque année à florange en
moselle promesses tenues le chef de
l'état qui a rappelé ses promesses à
l'égard du site symbolique malgré la
fermeture des hauts fourneaux je vous
propose d'écouter françois hollande
revient pourtant discuté tout après tout
les engagements pour des tenues aussi
les engagements macchione démocratie
mais omet les engagements en matière
d'investissement les engagements mavs en
matière de recherche publique
c'est ce que j'ai voulu démontrer et si
je viens chaque année c'est pour faire
la démonstration que non seulement la
parole est tenu des coûts allait même
plus loin
première tony dit le président de la
république moi je voudrais aussi aller
un petit peu plus loin comme l'a dit le
président de la république et gandrange
pour nicolas sarkozy et à florange pour
françois hollande ce sont des symboles
très fort pour le quinquennat de ces
deux présidents ont bien tenu et non
tenues oui parce que quand on entend
françois hollande dire promesse tenue
il revient à chaque année à florange
vont j'ai noté qu'il était obligé de
passer par une porte dérobée parce qu'il
semble que tous les salariés et anciens
salariés du site n'était pas n'étaient
pas convaincus du reclassement donc bon
si relativise les choses disons qu'il y
aura au moins une promesse de tenues
c'est que chaque année il fera un détour
certes par une porte dérobée mais il ira
à florange voies de communication oui
moi aussi comme le symbole de ces usines
qui ont fermé que ce soit à gros drôle à
florange pour les hauts fourneaux ce cas
de symbole très fort des quinquennats
oui mais bien sûr l'industrie ne
fonctionne plus fonctionner de la même
façon oui alors ça c'est un autre sujet
qu'on peut qu'on peut ouvrir
effectivement on a un problème de
compétitivité de coût du travail est
d'une nécessité de réformes de structure
ce qui laisse a symbolisé par nicolas
normes et redit comme viens sur ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que sur le
coût du travail qui est un sujet majeur
en france on peut pas le résoudre par un
claquement de doigts on n'a pas une
mesure puis ça y est ça va être réglé il
ya besoin de temps mais il ya besoin
d'action pour diminuer ce coût du
travail
or le reproche que l'on fait que je fais
à françois hollande à son gouvernement
c'est de n'avoir porté aucune aucune
réforme de structure qui vise à baisser
le coût du travail
rien sur les retraites rien sur le temps
de travail
rien sur le financement de la protection
sociale sur ces sujets vous allez
chantier je n'ai rien aucune réforme
aucune explique aulas sarkozy en
apporter peut-être pas suffisamment et
on peut lui faire ce reproche et moi je
l'accepté volontiers et j'en suis
solidaire parce que j'étais aussi
président du groupe parlementaire à ce
moment là donc je suis complaisance de
di resta est aussi quelque part le vôtre
oui mais tout à fait bien évidemment
l'assument collectivement sur les
retraites il fallait allonger la durée
de cotisations d'ae passé de 60 ans à 62
ans
je pense que ça n'est pas assez qu'il
faut mettre l'âge légal à 65 ans sur le
financement de la protection sociale
on a essayé de le basculer sur
l'assiette tva
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui permettait de
baisser le coût du travail c'est à dire
d'arrêter de financer la protection
sociale uniquement sur le travail
donc ça permettait de redonner du
salaire aurait augmenté salaire net et
de baisser le coût du travail pour les
entreprises mais on l'a voté trop tard
et donc on a un certain nombre de
reproches à suez simplement les réformes
de structure nicolas sarkozy les a fait
vraiment pas suffisamment peut-être trop
tard les engagés françois hollande rien
rien rien depuis deux ans alors
justement réformes de structure mardi à
l'assemblée nationale ce sont dessiner
les contours d'une nouvelle carte de
france et c'est une carte de france à
xiii région vous allez la découvrir les
députés ont adopté la réforme
territoriale en seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale à vote serré jeudi
la commission mixte paritaire qui
réunissait députés et sénateurs attiches
a échoué le texte va donc à nouveau être
examiné par les sénateurs et l'assemblée
devrait ensuite adopté la version
définitive d'ici la fin de l'année
christian jacob on a envie de dire tout
ça pour ça est ce qu'il n'ya pas de la
perte de temps est ce qu'il ne faut pas
rationaliser le travail parlementaire
toutes ces navettes que l'on voit de ce
texte
le fond du problème c'est que encore une
fois c'est une opération de
communication
aucune réforme de structure nous savions
nous avons aujourd'hui 4,4 strap de
collectivités commune l'intercommunalité
le conseil général le conte
régionales nous nous avions engagé une
réforme de structure de fonds qui visait
de ramener ces quatre strates à trois
strates
c'est à dire en créant le conseiller
territorial on a poussé on aboutissait à
terme à la fusion des deux collectivités
région ont été supprimés non mais
attendez je voudrais juste action ça
promet nous étions engagés sur cette
réforme de structure qui visait donc un
fusionner départements et régions on se
retrouvait donc avec trois strates
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que 2,4 strates de collectivités
on passe à trois noms est-ce qu'on reste
à quatre noms on en crée une cinquième
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir la
commune l'intercommunalité le conseil
général le conseil régional et les
métropoles
donc on baisse les dotations aux
collectivités et on en crée une de plus
ce qui fait donc les collectivités n'ont
plus de financement pour investir et
donc tout cet argent ne sert qu'à
financer du fonctionnement pour du
fonctionnement c'est une hérésie
cette réforme c'est n'importe quoi mais
faire il se répand dans le sens de
l'europe de l'est mais le sujet n'est
pas là le sujet c'est dès l'enfance du
contribuable est ce que cette réforme
apporte quelque chose oui ou non elle
est catastrophique
il n'y aura pas d'économie parce qu'on
crée une strate de plus et en plus on
diminue les dotations donc ce qui veut
dire que les collectivités au moins de
capacité d'investissement et aussi du
fonctionnement pour du fonctionnement ne
distinguait pas cette prime usine à gaz
c'est en plus au delà de ça on n'a même
pas défini les compétences mais ça va
arriver un candidat mais je m'y
attendais pas et se fiche du monde
définir un effet de tous les temps mais
bien sûr mais définir un périmètre de
collectivités en disant ce qu'on y fera
on verra après l'important c'est de
créer une collectivité de plus allons-y
c'est vraiment comme du socialisme
d'accord dans tout ce qu'il a de plus
pervers mais il essaye d'avancer quelque
part aussi je veux pas falloir défenseur
mais je dis vous propose que ce que dit
manuel valls il dit nous sommes dans le
camp des réformateurs vous vous êtes
plutôt d'un corps des conservateurs ceux
qui ne veulent rien faire bouger de
rester figé
qu'est ce que vous dites mais mais mais
je dis qu'il ne fait aucune réforme
c'est la fuite en avant monsieur valse
tant qu'il s'agit d'être dans le verbe
est très courageux dans l'action il est
inexistant
qu'est ce qu'il fait comme réforme y
créer une collectivité de plus vous
croyez qu'on ment
deux collectivités en france qu'on a
besoin d'en rajouter des strates avec
toujours un coût supplémentaire
ces métropoles et vont vivre de quoi de
l'argent du contribuable donc encore ni
des taxes supplémentaires encore des
infos supplémentaires et aucune capacité
d'avis que vous en vous appropriant vous
serez obligés d'augmenter les impôts
locaux
j'essaye d'éviter de le faire j'étais
j'ai fait partie des villes de plus de
10 mille habitants qui ont baissé les
impôts sous le précédent mandat et j'ai
finalement j'ai un objectif de tenir de
ne pas augmenter les impôts mais c'est
effectivement pas de jury est très clair
lundi devant la mf devant l'association
des maires de france je n'aurai pas le
fort justement tu es moi je vais essayer
d'éviter de le faire mais mais je n'en
suis pas convaincu puisque en baissant
les dotations et en créant une
collectivité une strate de plus c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi
alors avant sur le paseo mercredi
dernière ligne droite pour les candidats
à la présidence de l'ump nicolas sarkozy
bruno le maire a re marie tossou 3 sur
la dernière ligne de départ trois hommes
pour un poste la présidence de l'ump
tous ont des propositions différentes on
voit ça avec elisa berthelot mais il
veut reprendre le parti en main et tout
changé à l'ump grand favori nicolas
sarkozy a pourtant à peine précisé
pendant sa campagne ces projets pour
l'après élection changer de nom
supprimer les courants créer un grand
parti regroupant la droite et le centre
oui mais peu de détails supplémentaires
en meeting
nicolas sarkozy parle de la france
presque comme si le candidate à la
présidence de l'elysée et non à celle de
l'ump
la grande formation politique moderne
que nous allons faire émerger ne sera
pas qu'une grande force d'opposition
elle sera une grande force de
proposition d'imagination face aux
grandes mutations du monde à toutes les
crises qu'elles engendrent et a toutes
les chances qu'elle offre aux audacieux
et vous verrez mes chers amis
qu'ensemble nous allons réussir de
grandes choses
bruno le maire lui a choisi une autre
manière de faire campagne
devant des salles plus petites le
candidat défend sa doctrine
le renouveau des idées des élites des
pratiques
mais contrairement à son rival lui veut
garder l'ump sans alliance avec le
centre
je veux qu'on garde le nom de l'ump
c'est très important c'est comme ça que
les militants ump vont trancher est-ce
que le 29e rang milliards de l'ump ce
que je propose ou est ce que l'ump
disparaît c'est quand même pas un choix
anecdotique est ce que on assume ce que
je veux un positionnement de droite avec
des idées de droite pour l'ump ou est ce
qu'au contraire on essaye d'aller vers
une fusion avec lui dit le centre pour
faire un grand ensemble qui n'est pas
très clair c'est des choix absolument
fondamentaux le credo d'hervé mariton la
transparence dans la gestion du parti et
pour se démarquer de ses rivaux
le candidat outsider rappelle que lui
n'a jamais été rattrapé par les affaires
qui minent l'ump moi je vous dis les
choses au mieux très clair il faudra
aller au bout assuré une complète
transparence et en même temps ça n'est
pas le seul sujet de l'avenir l'ump j'ai
aussi cette force évidemment de dire que
des trois candidats je suis le seul des
trois ne pas avoir été en a fait avec
bygmalion ça c'est une réalité concrète
et une fois qu'on a dit cela
pour l'essentiel on s'attache à l'avenir
sur un point au moins les trois
candidats s'accordent aucun ne s'est
officiellement déclarée comme candidat à
la primaire pour 2010 est pour l'instant
et cette élection à la tête de l'ump
c'est notre zone de la semaine
frédéric dabi bonjour vous êtes
directeur département d'opinion et
stratégie d'entreprise à l'ifop
quel regard vous portez sur cette
campagne de l'ump est ce une campagne
honnête contrairement à la dernière
c'est une campagne qui s'est passé qui
s'est plutôt bien passé qui a été
marquée par le retour de nicolas sarkozy
sur la scène politique par une campagne
très longue et très efficace de terrain
de banc de le maire parent hervé mariton
qui a réussi à imposer son thème de
mariage pour tous à la seule fois où les
trois candidats ont été ensemble c'était
lors du meeting du sens commun
et puis bon cette campagne restera aussi
marqué par ce qui s'est passé à bordeaux
les sifflets parvenu alain juppé deux
cent soixante mille adhérents à peu près
un plus ou moins qui sont qui vont
devoir voter ce week-end impossible pour
vous de faire des sondages mais tout à
fait il faut avoir c'est l'honnêteté des
liens qu'on peut pas faire des sondages
pour faire un sondage il faut lui il
faut il faut il faut un fichier donc les
sondages et qui sont faits par quelques
instituts mais pas par l'ifop sont faits
auprès des sympathisants pour pouvoir
faire un sondage efficace il faut avoir
du fichier des adhérents de l'ump ce
n'est pas possible
les questions posées là sont des
questions de préférence auprès des
sympathisants au créateur d'une surprise
christian jacob a bien sûr c'est les
militants qui décident vous y croyez
vous à quoi est la surprise je sais pas
ça dépend ce que je sais que vous avez
décidé de ne pas donner votre choix de
vote personnel et quelque chose quand
même quelqu'un vous a surpris pas dans
cette campagne un des candidats non je
trouve qu'on a eu
l'analyse de frédéric dabi est parfaite
c'est à dire que on a effectivement une
campagne s'est bien passé d'abord au
delà on peut toujours y avoir quelques
quelques phrases un peu malheureux ici
ou là mais d'abord ça n'a pas une manne
et des combines des candidats plus
souvent de leur entourage que des
candidats eux mêmes ils ont parcouru la
france chacun avec leur tempérament leur
conviction sur le fond objectivement n'y
a pas de grande différence c'est plus
des différences de personnalité et de
de tempérament et d'expérience et
croissent et vous ne le maire vous êtes
d'accord comment oui oui c'est vrai que
l'écran non vous ne bruno le maire parce
que la presse
globalement dudit disons le avec pas
envie peut-être de revoir nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui et donc il ya eu les
candidats qui se présente en outsider on
était plus beaucoup plus portée
médiatiquement que nicolas sarkozy voilà
robert candidat des médias
c'est un peu ce que vous n'y êtes pas
porté peu beaucoup plus portée
effectivement médiatiquement mais mais
c'est aussi révélateur de quelque chose
simplement est ce qu'il n'est pas
content parce que j'avais une envie de
renouveau au sein du parti c'est ce
qu'on entend chez les sympathisants les
militants bruno le maire on verra sur
les militants attendent en attendant
samedi soir vous savez moi je suis
beaucoup plus prudent que quelques que
cela mais il ya eu effectivement parce
que personne au départ on attendait
plutôt peut-être bruno le maire comme
candidat c'est à cette élection
donc du coup il ya eu un soutien assez
large de la précision si on prend le
nombre de papiers bond par rapport à
hervé mariton
moi je pense qu'hervé mariton est
sous-estimée dans l'est dans les
résultats que l'on entend et j'obtiens
connaît maintenant et je sais gré à
l'effort de ne pas rentrer dans des
sondages parce qu'effectivement les
sondages ne veulent rien dire dans la
mesure où on n'a pas un fichier on n'a
pas un corps électoral définit un
listing est très compliqué de faire un
sondage aimé couramment caricature hervé
mariton sur le mariage pour pour tous
moi je les comme collègue parlementaire
ça fait partie des piliers de
l'assemblée parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui est sur tous les sujets qui étaient
très pointu techniquement et très
travailleur que l'on voit beaucoup dans
l'hémicycle et je pense qu'il peut avoir
une reconnaissance peut-être plus
important qu'on de avec un score plus
haut et comme un événement à bayonne
marquer cette campagne ce sont les
sifflets samedi dernier à bordeaux
sifflé contre alain juppé dans son
propre fief écouter plus que jamais
convaincu de la nécessité d'un large
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
si nous voulons battre le parti
socialiste face à la montée du front
national
je répète
l'ump a été constitué sur la base de
l'union et du centre et je continuerai à
militer qu'on ce rassemblement de la
droite et du son frédéric dabi cette
image elle a marqué cette campagne
acquis et nuit c'est vrai qu'elle a
marqué c'est vrai que c'est l'acte lourd
de cette campagne c'est vrai qu'elle
préfigure le futur affrontement sans
doute des primaires entre alain juppé et
nicolas sarkozy et c'est vrai que c'est
bruno le maire a plutôt bien exploiter
cette cet événement puisque même si là
c'est le seul qui a osé en fait
affronter directement nicolas sarkozy il
n'est jamais apparu comme le diviseur et
il a exploité cette quand cette cet
événement en se disant le rempart à la
future guerre des chefs et n'oublions
pas ce que les sympathisants je préviens
des sympathisants ump redoutent c'est la
réactivation des querelles de personnes
qui l'ont connu
ils ont connu chirac-giscard ils ont
connu sarkozy dominique de villepin copé
et fillon en 2012 qui ne veulent pas je
pense un affrontement juppé semble
logique
juppé sarkozy mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être le premier acte de ce qui
commencera peut-être dès le 30 novembre
c'est c'est à dire cette course d'un an
et demi à la primaire ump
je préfère côté ça peut être là aussi
rien mes chèvres sur les sifflets je
pense qu'il faut aussi relativiser les
choses
à partir du moment où on est dans la vie
publique qu'on va dans des dans des
salles publiques
on va prendre ça moi je viens du
syndicaliste cgt pendant 15 ans 17 ans
leader syndical des assemblées chaude on
se fait secouer
c'est un risque et ça lui a pas plu mais
bien entendu ça fait pas plaisir mais
dans la vie dit que c'est dangereux mais
dans la vie dans la vie dans la vie
politique et publique
ça nous est arrivé à tous c'est arrivé à
nicolas sarkozy c'est arrivé à certains
moments à jacques chirac
tous les leaders politiques
koné cela et donc il faut qu'ils se
nomment d'état pour pouvoir affronter ça
non il faut il faut tout simplement
relativiser ramener les accords est ce
que parce que nicolas sarkozy au métier
comme un bébé mort ajoute un petit peu
un homme politique digne de ce nom n'a
pas peur de se confronter aux idées des
autres elle a été tout simplement encore
une fois la jupe est sifflée dans cette
salle à bordeaux non mais enfin moi je
vous dis tout tout un bon c'est toujours
regrettable mais en même temps
relativisons les shows un petit peu plus
loin parce que finalement celui qui est
visé la danse c'est françois bayrou
c'est cette alliance de françois bayrou
avec fruits sont sûrs ils défient
popularité on veut dire qu'hormis
comprendre pourquoi fred avec des amis
c'est cette primaire est toute la
question va se poser sur la presse sur
le lendemain de cette élection c'est
d'abord vous avez raison c'est d'abord
les contours de cette primaire ump est
ce que les électeurs sont prises vont
aller voter massivement il ya aussi
cette une certaine obsession de nicolas
sarkozy sur françois bayrou alors c'est
vrai que françois bayrou a appelé à
voter pour françois hollande mais il
faut dire aussi qu'une majorité des
électeurs françois bayrou dieu de
premier tour ont voté pour nicolas
sarkozy au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et la stratégie de jupes
et qu'on voit dans les premières
enquêtes très présidentiel bien sûr
elles ne veulent rien dire bien sûr on
est très loin de en fait les chiens
c'est que alain juppé mort très
largement sur l'électorat bayrou 2012 ce
qui lui permet d'être pour l'instant le
seul à pouvoir contrer marine le pen au
1er mai où c'est le coq d'adp la gauche
une possible hausse n'est pas très
sérieux de dire ça le clivage gauche
droite et je pense aux puissants jacob
muer confirmant existe quand même
fortement en france que charge existe
que françois bayrou il a sa place dans
une primaire c'est à françois bayrou de
nous dire s'il se reconnaît dans les
valeurs de l'ue attendait mais c'est à
lui de nous le dire françois bayrou a
appelé à faire battre nicolas sarkozy à
faire élire françois hollande s'il a
changé d'avis qu'il le dise mais qu'il
le dise clairement quand là aussi sur ce
que représente françois méro moi je le
vois à l'assemblée mon modem c'est un
député il ya 200 députés ump dont si
françois bayrou dit oui j'ai fait une
erreur je me suis trompé
j'aurais dû soutenir nicolas sarkozy et
je me reconnais dans les valeurs de
l'ump on verra on verra moratoire
on est probablement attendre qu'il le
dise merci beaucoup frédéric pour
pouvoir éclairer sur cette élection à
l'ump et cette semaine les maires de
france tenait leur congrès le congrès
des maires de france s'est ouvert cette
semaine sur fond de grogne d'économies à
trouver bien évidemment le premier
ministre est venu quand même faire
quelques annonces détails et réactions
venir ceci manuel valls attendu de pied
ferme par les maires de france et par le
nouveau président de leur association
françois baroin s'est montrée très
offensive pour son premier discours
manuel valls se devait de répondre par
une annonce phare et c'est sur les
rythmes scolaires que le premier
ministre a voulu rassurer les élus nous
avons donc décidé que l'aide de l'état
au développement des activités
périscolaires sera pérennisée au delà de
l'année 2015 2016
autrement dit le fonds d'amorçage sera
désormais un fonds de soutien aux
communes soit une enveloppe annuelle de
400 millions d'euros
le premier ministre a aussi annoncé un
renforcement du soutien aux politiques
locales de logements dans les travées
les avis sont mitigés des annonces on en
a pas eu beaucoup en fait on a eu juste
la pérennisation de la
à du fonds d'amorçage c'est tout con
mais ça on le savait plus ou moins
puisque ça a été évoqué lors dès lors
des débats va tout à fait dans le bon
sens on c'est un projet qui était très
très ambitieux il faut le prendre
cocktail l'impression que le premier
ministre ne comprenait pas les rôles et
les missions des mers comment ils vont
évoluer par rapport aux baisses des
dotations
je crois qu'il le sait mais n'a pas
voulu le dire de façon très claire pour
ses premiers pas à la mf françois baroin
réclament une réunion d'urgence sur les
finances locales
un appel entendu manuel valls donne
rendez vous au maire début 2015 pour une
nouvelle négociation
c'est vrai qu'on a senti les maires très
très en colère que surgit comme vous
aussi vous êtes un maire en colère
oui oui on est en colère parce que je
vous dis autant les économies elles sont
à faire par tous il n'est pas choquant
que les collectivités doivent en faire
bien évidemment mais ce qui se passe là
réduire les dotations et créer des
collectivités de plus facile trop vite
et trop fort trop a dit alain juppé
le site est tout le temps mais c'est un
peu ce qui agite devant le congrès oui
enfin c'est surtout une réforme qui
ressemble à rien la réforme portée par
le gouvernement c'est surtout ça avec
l'adhésion de dota la wii en créant
qu'est ce que ça change pour vous les 11
milliards de dotation au moins en tant
que maire et qui sont avalés ferré beck
concrètement moi c'est une diminution de
ma capacité d'investissement et à partir
de là les conséquences et son direct sur
les kilomètres de voirie je vais faire
en moins sur mon budget l'année
prochaine sur des recrutements qu aurait
pu être prévu on va essayer de
rationaliser
c'est essentiellement sur de
l'investissement que l'on va réduire les
choses donc moi je pense que il y à un
effort à faire dans les dents les
collectivités sur le statut de la
fonction publique c'est une vraie
réforme de structure à porter réduire le
nombre de stratèges encore une fois
c'est pas en regroupant les régions
le sujet c'est de réduire le nombre de
strates de collectivités ce que à chaque
strate vous avez un coup un exécutif
vous avez un coût de fonctionnement vous
avez des financements supplémentaires
attribués donc c'est autant qui ne va
pas aller à l'entreprise de bt la
période du secteur que toi sur les
bâtiments sur les gros travaux conçus
à l'heure actuelle on les arrête on les
supprime qu'est ce qui se passe on
décale on décale souvent mais donc quand
on les décale ça veut dire concrètement
les faits pendant l'année est donc la
conséquence directe c'est que le carnet
de commandes des entreprises de btp bin
va diminuer c'est à dire un carnet de
commandes qui étaient pleins il ya de
cela deux ans encore il y avait
pratiquement un an d'avancé de travail
ils sont passés à six mois on est plutôt
à 3 mois une pme qui a trois mois
le moindre incident le moindre impayés
elle s'effondre et est la conséquence
directe c'est celle-là est l'autre thème
qu'on a abordé lors du congrès des
maires de france
évidemment les rythmes scolaires une
fois le fric sur une veine c'est
exactement ça manuel valls a très
clairement annoncé que le fonds serait
pérennisée c'était un fonds d'amorçage
vous avez un fonds pérenne qu'est ce que
vous en process que c'est une victoire
symbolique que vous obtenez la auprès de
nom la victoire symbolique c'était de
retirer cette réforme qui n'a pas de
sens c'est très fort envoyé dans une
ville comme la mienne à provins c'est
six points l'équivalent de six points
d'impôts ménage donc alors je vais pas
augmenter les impôts mais en revanche il
y à des dépenses que je faisais que je
ne ferai pas donc vous voyez ce que ça
représente 6 points d'impôts ménages et
finalement pour avoir quoi pour
augmenter le temps en études surveillées
pour augmenter le temps en garderie
qu'est ce que ça va apporter de plus aux
enfants
si ce n'est de se lever une journée de
plus par semaine de bonheur enfin tout
le matin mais la question et décoche
économique parce que vous vouliez
l'argent pour que ça puisse fonctionner
non moi je ne voulais pas de cette
réforme comprend de la réforme
ensuite le financement c'est toujours de
l'impôt c'est le contribuable c'est le
même c'est la même poche qu'on la prenne
au niveau local au niveau national si la
même poche donc claque il ya une
dotation tant mieux mais mais je veux
dire c'est pas sale l'intelligence que
devait avoir ce gouvernement et ce que
devait faire manuel valls en arrivant à
matignon s'était retiré cette réforme
ça c'était du bon sens c'est un maire il
devait bien bien mesurer l'intérêt quoi
il l'a pas fait selon mais parce que ce
gouvernement s'est enfermé dans cette
doctrine de dire voilà j'ai lancé une
réforme je vais je vais au bout mais
c'est n'importe quoi sous selle c'est
très rare d'avoir une réforme qui fasse
l'unanimité contre elle par tous c'est à
dire que les enseignants sont cons
les chefs d'établissement sont contre
les maires sont contre les parents
d'élèves issus tous les maires sont à
90% les mères sans son compte ce qu'ils
ont fait ils l'ont fait contraints et
forcés en disant bon bah de toute façon
il ya les financements va le faire on le
fait avec de l'argent public pour
apporter quoi aux enfants qu'est ce
qu'il y a plus sa fin rien a passé un
autre thème où va revenir à l'assemblée
nationale qui essaye aussi de se
réformer un moins de questions écrites
ou aux nuits blanches
les députés se penchent sur le règlement
de l'assemblée nationale c'est en tout
cas une résolution présentée par le
président de l'assemblée claude
bartolone alors pour résumer il y aura
des collaborateurs ont un statut
les séances se termineront à une heure
du matin maximum et le nombre de
questions écrites sera limitée par
député qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
réformes christian jacob vous le
président du groupe ump stop à
l'inflation
tempête dans un verre d'eau la réforme
est pourquoi on change pas grand chose
d'abord limité le nombre de questions
moi je trouve ça choquant c'est le droit
fondamental comme le droit fondamental
d'un d'amendements c'est un droit d'un
parlementaire lors qu'ils aimaient une
inflation
oui le valmirande fonde surtout que le
gouvernement l'exécutif méprise le
parlement et c'est là que moi
j'attendais le président de l'assemblée
nationale qu'il oblige le gouvernement
conformément à notre constitution à être
responsable devant le parlement et à
répondre aux questions qui sont posées
par les députés
ces questions normalement il y avait une
procédure qui était celle d'urgence
c'est à dire lorsqu'un président de
groupe signalait une question de savoir
répondre les quinze jours le
gouvernement ne tient plus compte et il
fallait que le président de notre
assemblée rappel à l'ordre ce
gouvernement qui en plein dérapage et
ses ministres qu'ils n'assument plus
leurs responsabilités
peut-être qu'ils devraient faire un peu
moins de qom et être un peu plus au
travail le ministre alors justement par
exemple sur les sur la question des
séances de nuit elles sont limitées
jusqu'à une heure du matin alors
symboliquement on verra plus les députés
travaillent à 3 heures du matin mais
derrière il ya aussi une question
financière c'est ensuite millions
d'euros d'économies oui dans certains
cas mais derrière il y aussi une
question financière 38 millions d'euros
d'économies ça va dans le bon sens je
vais bien sûr bien sûr
simplement je pense aussi qu'il serait
beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup moins légiférer le nombre de
textes mais mais mais qui soit aussi de
dépasser le texte macron on nous annonce
164 article mais c'est n'importe quoi
si monsieur macron a envie de se lancer
dans la littérature qui fasse qu'il
écrive un roman c'est l'organisation du
travail une réforme non il ya aucune
réforme de structure et et un texte un
texte de 164 article c'est n'importe
quoi
d'abord si monsieur macron avait été
d'une fois dans sa vie je pense qu'il
sera un peu plus raisonnable
et encore s'il a envie de se lancer dans
l'écriture qu'il fasse autre chose qui
peut-être qu'il a d'ailleurs des talents
d'écrivain on verra mais en tout cas il
n'a pas de talents de législateur c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire
il porte une réforme sans aucune
concertation où on va avoir des phrases
pour ne rien dire dons qui permettent à
partir du moment où on commence à voir
l'attitude de l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale cette fois sur ce genre de
texte on ferait demain on va de
transition systématique on va on va
attendre de voir de voir le trc aussi on
vous rend un petit peu le bien par où le
temps cette fois est ce que vous faites
de l'opposition systématique sur la rd
164 ça dépend des textes ad pense qu'il
y aura dedans
or je sais qu'un texte de 160
cathartique ça n'est pas un texte ces
deux-là procès de la littérature pour ne
rien dire pour essayer d'exister pour
occuper le temps comme monsieur macron
en mal de notoriété les très soucieux de
son image se dit avec 164 article ma foi
j'ai durer un peu à l'assemblée donc je
vais avoir deux de l'image donc on me
verdure avec le nouveau ministre
oui oui parce que vous savez ces
premières réflexions sont entrés en
politique n'a pas été glorieuse et je
suis toujours très sceptique sur
l'arrivée des des personnalités qui
viennent de la société c'est pénible
je pense que non je pense que lorsqu'on
avec vous mais dans ce bundle wii mais
lorsque l'on à l'honneur oui mais avant
d'être ministre dé tenir
j'ai d'abord été des ventes et j'ai
d'abord été maire et ensuite je suis je
suis devenu ministre et je pense que ces
ministres qui n'ont aucune expérience de
terrain aucune expérience locale savent
pas ce que c'est que des attributions de
logements ils ne savent pas ce que c'est
que de mettre en place un plan local
d'urbanisme
ils savent pas ce que c'est que de gérer
une crèche que de gérer une halte
garderie et n'a aucune accusation comme
ça devenir ministre bah je pense que ça
s'est rarement couronnée par la réussite
il ya quelques expériences
revenons sur le travail parlementaire
mardi prochain les députés vont se
prononcer sur la reconnaissance de
l'état palestinien cette résolution de
reconnaissance incite le gouvernement à
reconnaître l'état de palestine en vue
d'obtenir un règlement du conflit
les précisions avec ahmed tazi c'est une
assemblée divisé qui va voter la
reconnaissance de l'état palestinien
le texte invite le gouvernement à
reconnaître l'état de palestine en vue
d'obtenir un règlement définitif du
conflit
à l'initiative de la démarche la
présidente de la commission des affaires
étrangères pour qui rien n'est pire que
le statu quo la situation sur le terrain
est d'abord extrêmement
violente très tendu et c'est précisément
parce qu'il est un blocage complet des
négociations parce que la colonisation
continue au point de compromettre l'idée
même d'une solution à deux états qui
pourtant nous savons est admise par la
communauté internationale et par le
gouvernement israélien
comme étant la solution pour la paix ce
vote un élément déclencheur de paix
c'est l'avis du chef de file du groupe
socialiste
nous voulons par ce texte après que
d'autres pays l'effet provoqué un
sursaut pour la paix valoriser ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les territoires
palestiniens
valoriser ce qui se passe en israël et
les prises de paroles qui disent ça ne
peut pas continuer comme cela
à gauche le texte sera soutenu avec
enthousiasme par les écologistes et le
front de gauche des votes similaire
viennent d'avoir lieu au parlement
britannique au sénat irlandais et au
congrès des députés espagnol différence
en france l'opposition en grande partie
ne soutient pas la démarche
les députés ump oscille entre la
non-participation vote et le vote contre
il n'appartient pas au parlement
français de reconnaître un état quel
qu'il soit c'est une question qui est
laissé à notre exécutif dont il préside
en hollande de prendre cette traçabilité
qu'il n'a plus qu'ils apprennent même si
je suis reste favorable à la
reconnaissance de l'état palestinien
je trouve que l' équilibre n'est pas
trouvée dans la motion à lui dit on
laissera les députés voter comme bon
leur semble alors qu'au front national
gilbert collard votre à contrer marion
maréchal-le pen pour la question doit
faire l'objet d'un débat ce vendredi et
d'un vote solennel mardi prochain
qui dit vote solennel dit scrutin public
la position du vote de chaque député
sera donc connu là christian jacob
quelle sera la consigne de vote
consigne globalement aujourd'hui on a 90
% des députés ump qui sont opposés à
cette à cette résolution pour pour
plusieurs raisons la première
la première raison c'est que la
reconnaissance d'un état ça relève de
l'exécutif est donc adopté ce type de
résolution
c'est affaiblir la voix de la france
soit le président de la république tient
compte de la résolution et à ce moment
là sa voix est affaibli puisqu'il
enfermé dans une position du parlement
soit il n'en tient pas compte et à ce
moment là cette résolution n'a aucun n'a
aucun intérêt
ces solutions c'est là je sais pas ce
qu'il en fera c'est la traduction d'un
président faible avec une voie qui n'est
pas portée contrairement à tous ses
prédécesseurs du général de gaulle à
nicolas sarkozy en passant par françois
mitterrand qui ont souvent été en
initiative sur ce dossier mais qu'il
été en tant que chef de l'état là on a
un président de la république qui
n'existe pas et donc qui se dérobe sous
une résolution débattu en catimini temps
d un sujet comme celui là
l'ump à 15 minutes de temps de parole à
quoi ça ressemble d'aller traiter cela
un vendredi matin
de cette manière on est dans clairement
et ce conformément à nos institutions
dans la responsabilité directe du
président de la république qui ne
l'assument pas et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on associations commerciales ou 2e 2e
deuxième élément de deuxième point nous
sommes tous unanimement tous les députés
ump sans exception favorable à la
reconnaissance des 2ème et alain la
coexistence des deux états mais au terme
d'un processus de paix clairement abouti
il est clair que ce processus de paix
n'est pas abouti aujourd'hui c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous refusons cette
cette résolution
donc voilà 90% des députés sont opposés
et alors nous verrons mardi
comment nous allons procéder certains me
disent moi je refuse de la cautionner
donc je n'irai même pas voter parce que
je ne cautionne pas ce système
d'autres disent moi je veux vraiment
marqué mon désaccord et j'irai voter
contre
voilà vous savez vous allez faire c'est
quand le définir la vision du groupe et
je vous dirai marc dion et mardi c'est à
vous engage aussi bien évidemment
fallait mais simplement le brouillage
d'abord avec mes collègues
parlementaires je suis leur président et
c'est dans ce cadre là je prendrai
maison mais comme israël de toute façon
ce sera une opposition à cette réforme
vise une résolution
nicolas sarkozy dit pas mais il faut
voter contre ils appellent les
parlementaires qui lui sont fidèles à
voter contre
ça vous embête que le président l'ancien
président roh semaines du démarrage non
je pense que si quelqu'un est légitime
pour parler de ce sujet c'est bien
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'il a été lui en
initiative
contrairement à françois hollande est
lui ne s'est pas dérobé de ses
responsabilités sur une résolution
parlementaire allait repasser encore une
fois à l'assemblée nationale qui a
examiné cette semaine une autre
proposition de résolution
c'est le plus de l'hebdo qui est
consacré aux 40 ans de la loi veil
c'est l'une des avancées majeures des
droits des femmes il ya quarante ans la
loi veil était adoptée elle aboutissait
ali vg france 2 a diffusé cette semaine
un téléfilm qui retrace le parcours le
combat de simone veil cerveau simon
barbarie l'a vu pour vous ils vous
résume ce documentaire sous les traits
de simone veil emmanuelle devos retrace
le combat de l'ancien ministre de la
santé pour faire adopter la loi celle
qui lie à 40 ans a légalisé
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
trois jours et deux nuits d'une bataille
acharnée à l'assemblée nationale c'est
l'argument et la temporalité de cette
fiction historique intitulée la loi bien
sûr madame le ministre
dans tous les cas si nous perdons la
gauche il n'y a pas le compte et on
rentre chez nous pour trouver les
solutions les flics et les arcanes de
cette maison mais j'ai peur que si le
docteur chignon tailleur gestuelle
intonations la ressemblance avec
l'ancien ministre est frappante
la ressemblance avec notre époque aussi
si la légalisation de l'avortement a
profondément transformé la société
française un tel geste ou s'impliquent
morale éthique religion libertés
individuelles ou encore droits des
femmes ne pouvaient que déchaîné les
passions en 1974
quarante ans plus tard cette
retranscription historique parfaitement
documenté ne semble pas avoir pris une
ride
la baisse de notre natalité nous laisse
présager la même dégradation profonde
dont la france a tant souffert
que dis-je dont elle a failli périr
le film a choisi de contourner la
personnalité de simone veil et son sens
politique pour se concentrer sur les
débats législatifs et sociétaux qui
précède sa loi un parti-pris justifier
chaque année en france plus de 200 mille
femmes ont recours à liv et g
cette semaine l'assemblée nationale
examinait une proposition de résolution
pour réaffirmer le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est un texte très symbolique et
quarante ans après la loi veil
vous l'avez co signée christian jacob
est ce que vous avez reçu comme toute
une série de vos collègues l'ump des
mails d'anti ivg ce lobbying puissant
qui s'est exprimé juste avant la
signature de cette résolution
pas à ma connaissance mais si j'en ai
reçu de poids était très attentif
moi je considère que c'est une
formidable avancée pour les femmes en
revanche bon est-ce qu'il fallait que le
commémoré par une résolution
bon ça a quelque chose ces propos de
résolutions objectivement non
objectivement non je pense qu'on aurait
pu le commémorer dit différemment moi je
suis très attaché à la loi veil encore
une fois je considère que c'est une
avancée formidable apport pour les
femmes maintenant on a eu le sentiment
que la gauche voulait s'accaparer cette
loi et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé un peu
désobligeant mais est ce que ça apporte
quelque chose de plus est-ce que ça
retire quelque chose à la loi veil non
c'est la raison pour laquelle je l'ait
signé mais je pense qu'on aurait pu
faire différemment pour commémorer le
quarantième anniversaire cette grande
loi aujourd'hui on sait que les femmes
rencontrent encore des difficultés pour
avorter que le sujet est encore tabou
on voit avec toutes les pressions
lobbying ou que vous avez reçue à ce que
justement il fallait célébrer ce que
c'était pas cette occasion nécessaire de
célébrer à la loi veil pour réaffirmer
ce droit des femmes non mais je pense
qu'il était important de 40 ans après 2
le de le faire ça ça ne me choque pas
mais de le faire par une résolution ou
un groupe politique essaye de
l'accaparer bon dans votre groupe
politique ceux qui ont voté contre ce
qu'ils ont fait avec les convictions qui
sont les leurs qui sont tout à fait
respectable mais qui sont aurait encore
à des prêts les traire à fanons sont
très très minoritaires au sein de toi
toi recruteurs un mois sur la pétition
mais toutes les convictions sont
respectables simplement 80 je crois 95
100 du groupe soutien à cette résolution
christian jacob un mois sur la famille
le conseil d'état se penche aujourd'hui
sur la circulaire taubira
y accorde la nationalité française aux
enfants nés de gestation par autrui à
l'étranger si conseil d'état valide
cette circulaire mais quelle sera la
réaction de votre compte de l'ump
moi je suis opposé à cette
reconnaissance par ce fait à partir du
moment où on reconnaît effectivement la
nationalité française ça veut dire que
deux fêtes
on va vers une reconnaissance de la gt1
et et je reste opposée à la
marchandisation du corps des femmes
ensuite on va se trouver dans une
situation très compliquée parce que vous
le savez comme moi tout le monde tous
les couples homosexuels n'ont pas tous
la capacité d'aller à l'étranger de
trouver une mère porteuse donc ses pairs
donc c'est le début de la gpa c'est pour
ça que je reste opposée je considère que
cette cette circulaire est illégale et
j'espère qu'elle sera elle ne reconnaît
pas la filiation cette circulaire elle
ne donne pas de livret de famille c'est
la nationalité de fait on est ravis on
gère on rentre dans l'engrenage c'est à
dire comment vous pouvez accepter la gpa
et ne pas reconnaître l'adoption après à
partir du moment porte ouverte la porte
est ouverte
c'est ce que je sais ce que je pense
c'est pour ça que je suis battu contre
cette circulaire
merci beaucoup question d'un grave
d'avoir participé à notre émission par
le maroc d'omar sy mario on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine bonne semaine à
tous